quoi chaque fois que j'entrais pour
siéger à l'Assemblée législative comme
on l'appelait dans le temps
j'apercevais sur la tour centrale du
Parlement le ninja
qui a mon avis était le symbole de notre
défunte c'est d'ailleurs ce député
indépendant dans les années 40 qui a eu
l'idée de doter le Québec d'un drapeau
distinctif un projet qui ne plaisait
pendant pas à Maurice Duplessis mais
qu'il accepte finalement il prononce une
allocution historique à l'Assemblée
législative alors que le drapeau flotte
déjà au Parlement
c'est la preuve que nous ne sommes pas
en tutelle que nous ne sommes pas en
curétel un discours qu'il répétera plus
tard au cours d'une conférence de presse
un drapeau c'est dire que nous sommes
quelqu'un qui nous descendons quelqu'un
que nous voulons vivre notre vie et
survivre
[Musique]
c'est un drapeau qui s'inspirait de la
bannière de carillon qui aurait été
utilisé lors de la bataille de 1758 il y
a un drapeau qui est fortement influencé
par l'Église catholique rien curé elle
fait filiatro curé de Saint-Judes tout
près de Saint-Hyacinthe qui va proposer
un fleur de lysée c'est à dire une croix
blanche avec des fleurs de lys mais
pointée vers le centre Maurice Duplessis
décide finalement que les lisses du
fleur de lysée seront redressés vers le
haut les associations les conseils
municipaux les paroisses tout le monde
demandait un drapeau par l'intermédiaire
de la Société Saint-Jean-Baptiste tout
le monde va se rallier les députés de la
presse anglophones va trouver que c'est
un bel emblème à des Largo debout le
chef de l'opposition libérale va saluer
l'emblème va saluer le drapeau ainsi de
suite donc ça va faire presque
immédiatement consensus donc c'est
vraiment un bon coup pour un premier
ministre et après
maintenant son drapeau un discours
merveilleusement repris dans la série
télévisée du Plessis le respect intégral
de nos prérogatives de nos droits et de
nos libertés
[Musique]
ici Jacques bissonner Radio-Canada
Montréal
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]